il a fait beau jour merci est d'être
avec nous alors ce conseil de défense
avec ce conseil de défense il s'agit
pour emmanuel macron de préparer la
rentrée mais aussi de rassurer les
français
oui effectivement après des messages
souvent contradictoires et une gestion
de la crise sanitaire qui est
globalement très critiqué il s'agit ici
pour l'exécutif de faire le point sur
les sur l'évolution de l'épidémie il
faut savoir que depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant la situation se
dégrade notamment en ile de france ou
encore dans les bouches-du-rhône où
depuis juillet on note une teinte au de
contamination qui a été multiplié par
trois alors par conséquent pour
l'exécutif aujourd'hui le but de ce
conseil de défense et d'affiner ans les
protocoles sanitaires en vigueur
notamment pour la rentrée des classes
mais aussi pour les entreprises alors
concrètement depuis ce matin 10 heures
les ministres se penche sur la situation
épidémique
département par département avec cette
question faut-il accroître les
contraintes dans les zones les plus
touchées
autre question sur la table depuis ce
matin celle de la gratuité des masques
qui sont obligatoires maintenant dans
les établissements scolaires mais aussi
en entreprise alors pour l'exécutif
l'objectif de ce conseil de défense et
de contenir la propagation du virus mais
aussi sans pour autant freiner la
relance de l'économie et c'est bien là
le fragile équilibre auquel le chef de
l'état doit trouver
merci beaucoup il a farz ou en direct de
l elysée